British Prime Minister Boris Johnson is
calling for national unity after his
Conservative Party's landslide election
victory he is urging people to quote let
the healing begin the UK has been
fiercely divided since the vote to leave
the European Union three years ago now
and the election result means Briggs it
will happen in January but it also means
Johnson will face big challenges in
keeping the United Kingdom United en Lee
is in London with the latest on this and
good morning good morning Jeff I don't
think anyone saw that massive victory
coming but when I talked to voters at
the polls there was a lot of frustration
at three years of political paralysis
after thrashing his political opponent
Prime Minister Boris Johnson took a
victory lap first a buckingham palace to
meet the Queen to get permission to form
a government and to get it done then to
northern England and newly but gotten
spoils an industrial heartland that
never elected his party before because I
believe that the people thrilling are
three and a half years ago who voted
today that should have respected that
and that didn't the Prime Minister is
also on a charm offensive playing mr.
nice guy to try to heal a country deeply
polarized by brexit I want you to know
that we in this one nation Conservative
government will never ignore your good
and positive feelings of warmth and
sympathy towards the other nations of
Europe but as the Prime Minister
prepares to leave the EU trouble is
brewing for him north of the border
Scottish nationalists won a resounding
victory now they're demanding their own
independence vote from the UK this is
not about asking what is Johnson or any
other Westminster politician for
permission it is instead an assertion of
the democratic rate of the people of
Scotland to determine our own future
brexit now seems inevitable but possibly
at the cost of a United Kingdom and
Johnson's already ruled out another
Scottish independence vote but there's
but
central trouble for him on another front
Nash last one in Northern Ireland -
possibly
further down the road paving the way for
a vote on Irish reunification but if
there's any silver lining here for the
Prime Minister Wales hasn't said
anything about wanting to leave Dana
all right and it's been fascinating to
watch from afar thank you